foreign
[Applause]
thanks everyone thanks for coming
um so yeah I'm going to talk today about
how philosophy can improve your life
um and it's only half an hour so I'm
probably not going to cover like
literally everything but let's try and
give you like a flavor of um how I think
it can be useful
start with this question what's
philosophy for
I mean sometimes people ask this
um
and it is kind of baffling because that
one
do you mean what's it for
um
it's basically a toolbox you know
sometimes when we
um talk at you know philosophy lecturers
talk at open days to a level students
um and you'll sometimes get this
question you know what is what is
philosophy what what do you do with it
um and it's kind of a toolbox it's a set
of
um strategies and
tools and techniques that you can use to
gain clarity about
any sort of issue really you know
whatever you choose to apply it to
so here are a few I mean a
non-exhaustive list of um what
philosophy can be good for
so identifying and articulating hidden
assumptions
I used to teach a logic class to
undergraduates and undergraduates don't
tend to like logic it's got too many
symbols in it and they kind of came to
do an arts degree and they kind of end
up like what the hell are you giving me
I didn't choose to do maths so I used to
kind of try and sell it to them early on
by sort of saying like this makes this
is going to make you really good at
winning arguments with people now even
if you never use it again if you're just
in a debate with somebody about whatever
it might be politics whatever
there's some techniques I'm going to
teach you that will help you
dismantle your opponent so I mean
probably not actual opponents not the
enemies but you know whoever you're
talking to sort of work out where the
flaws are in their arguments
um sort of hone in your objections on
the actual problems with what they're
saying and build your case
um
I'm one issue where you know the reason
I've the reason I've used the word
hidden there is that often when you're
debating with somebody
um
they will be building an argument based
on assumptions that they might not even
realize they have
and sometimes that's okay you know
sometimes you might be arguing with
somebody and you both
um you know say you're arguing about
politics and you you both are working
with an assumption that equality is
important something like that I mean
that seems important and acceptable
right but but you might not realize
you're doing it and sometimes people do
that with um problematic assumptions as
well
spotting dodgy reasoning I mean kind of
hopefully self-explanatory
um asking why add infant item so
philosophers are a bit like toddlers in
this respect
um
and it's kind of socially unacceptable
you know if somebody's saying something
to you and you just you might ask why
once but you're not going to keep on
doing that
um unless you're a philosopher and it is
it is actually a useful technique right
because every time you ask why you get a
little bit deeper into
um the the foundational
justifying claims
um the underpin what what somebody's
learning so philosophers aren't afraid
to do that and analogies are arguing by
analogy is a really important
philosophical technique
um and it's basically a way of saying
um
you know this is what we think about
this issue
um we can compare it to the way that
we're thinking about this other issue
and if they're kind of similar in what
looked like to be relevant respects then
you should be treating them similarly so
just an example there
um you might have heard of the um the
watchmaker argument of the existence of
God this is something that Richard
Dawkins talks about in his blind
watchmaker
um
argument
um where the the reasoning goes that
suppose you find a watch in the middle
of a field
um and it's you know it's it's
it works fine it's it's it it looks like
a watch it functions like a watch
um how would you assume that it's got
there
and the answer you're supposed to
come up with is somebody's put
somebody's designed this it hasn't just
kind of popped up there by accident
there's a designer behind it
and so this is supposed to be an analogy
for the world you know the world is a
kind of complex and well-ordered system
and so it's kind of like the watch you
don't just assume that it's popped up by
itself you're seeing that somebody's
created it so
um the uh if that argument is successful
you're supposed to end up believing in
God here's zooming out a bit this is
what we this is what philosophers do
it's kind of looking under the Bonnet of
reality or looking under the hood of
reality if you're an American
um it's just a sort of General a way of
gaining a better understanding of the
world around us
um
what part of reality you're looking at
depends on what you're interested in
you can examine anything you like really
with um philosophical techniques
but I'm going to give you a bit of My
Own Story
um
so when I started out I mean I've been a
philosopher kind of most of my adult
life I've got quite a quite a boring
career I started at 18 doing a a
Philosophy degree and then I just
carried on and I kind of went into it
for a few years and that was a bad idea
but then I came back to philosophy and
that's kind of the way it's been ever
since
and I was always sort of interested
especially early on in um quite kind of
abstract issues like
um things to do with our experience of
time
um it was like you know is is backwards
causation in theory possible you know it
could future events cause earlier events
um what's a person
you know what makes you the same person
now that you were when you were six
years old and so on
um free will all this sort of stuff
um and the reason I'm saying that's
quite abstract is because it's um
philosophers are arguing about and a
hundred years from now they're probably
still going to be we are probably still
going to be arguing about it there's
nothing really that's kind of there's no
kind of resolution
um you're not going to make a discovery
that's going to kind of all right okay
that's what free will is
um
as I've as the years have ticked by I've
become sort of increasingly interested
in more applied issues so um the stuff
that just kind of matters in our
day-to-day lives
um so I kind of moved quite slowly into
applied ethics philosophy of medicine
philosophy of mental health and
Psychiatry and so on um I more recently
got interested in philosophy of language
um
and more recently still so like the kind
of are getting more and more applied and
a couple of years ago it occurred to me
that actually philosophy could be a
really useful tool
in just helping people live their lives
just kind of helping people
be happier success more successful and
so on and none of this is particularly
new these are this kind of approach is
quite ancient if you read sort of
people like Aristotle
um one of the driving questions there is
sort of how can we live Better Lives
um so I have sort of gradually I kind of
I tend to write more for General
audiences these days because
um it has to be kind of
the public in general who's kind of
interested in
um oh God you know sort of how how can I
use social media in a healthy way um how
should I think about the friends I've
made online this this sort of stuff
rather than sort of academic
philosophers
most recently I started a podcast I to
really want to kind of plug plug it here
but just like a sort of I guess like to
give you uh to give you an idea of the
the journey I've taken like this is just
like a
Apple podcast screenshot of some of the
most recent episodes so I'm trying to
apply philosophy to
um the sorts of problems that people
grapple with every day
so that's the kind of um that's been
what's been going on with me and I'm
going to give you a little taste of um
a way that you could use philosophy like
kind of right now to start
um being happier and living Better Lives
so I'm going to focus on like an example
because I'm not going to talk about
everything but here's a familiar problem
um I did quite a bit of coaching these
days and um I am kind of telling you
about a problem that comes up again and
again with people that I see
um
we don't see the world as it really is
most of the time we don't think about
that you think like you know the objects
you see in the world are really there
that you're seeing them kind of
accurately
as they as they would be if you weren't
there observing them at all you know we
don't tend to think that either the
world we observe stiffer differs in any
significant way from the way that we
perceive it but actually that's wrong
and there's sort of a tradition of
hundreds of years actually philosophers
telling you exactly why that's wrong
um I'm not particularly interested in
perception here I'm interested in the
beliefs that we hold about ourselves
because
just as your your senses filter the
world around you
um the beliefs that you hold about
yourself
do the same and we don't always realize
that because you might not realize that
you hold the beliefs that that do this
so what do I mean I mean deeply held
beliefs right these kind of like sort of
core beliefs that you've probably had
since childhood right the sort of things
that you might if you wanted to uncover
them you might have to go just like
Psychotherapy something like that
um
so you might not be able to kind of you
know someone to ask you like like what
are your fundamental beliefs the ones
that kind of govern your decisions and
your choices as you go through the world
you might have to think hard about it
and you still might not come up with an
answer but they do show up in the
choices you make and by reflecting on
the choices you make and the choices you
don't make this can kind of give you an
insight into the sorts of beliefs that
are guiding you here
so I'm going to focus on some examples
um I tried to choose some examples that
I hope you know lots of us can relate to
but you know as I'm going through it
maybe you can sort of reflect and think
of um
of some examples from your own life so
suppose this happens
you apply for a job and you get rejected
so you feel bad
what else do you think about it
um well here's what lots of people think
if you get rejected from a job this is
evidence that I'm not good enough
another example you do something at work
and your boss doesn't say anything
positive about it
and so you might think she thinks what
I've done is rubbish
final example I promise your friend
doesn't use as many happy emojis as
usual in her text message so you think
she's annoyed with me
okay so there's this kind of negative
judgments that are that we make just as
we go through life you know sort of just
the way somebody might respond to us or
a decisions that we're confronted with
it's not just somebody's manner you know
we're sort of constantly drawing these
little conclusions about what these
things that we encounter mean
and here is where we kind of get an
insight into what some of the core
beliefs that filter our reality might be
so we have I'm not good enough
right you get rejected from a job and
you can if you conclude that you're not
good enough as a result of that that's
only something that you're going to
conclude if you already believed that
right if you think you're fantastic and
you get rejected from a job so it's kind
of like a face it takes idiots they just
don't recognize my immense Worth or
something like that these are beliefs
that you hold before this stuff happens
and then when certain things happen you
can interpret those happenings through
the lens of these beliefs
and you think you're seeing evidence for
them but you're not really
now here's a problem with those beliefs
in case you haven't spotted or read
that's a problem with those beliefs
they're foundational right they're kind
of they kind of make up Who You Are
and that means that they
you hold them and you kind of build
other stuff on them
and what you build on them is
unsupported because those beliefs are
wrong or at least they're unjustified
what might you build if you believe I'm
not good enough or I'm incompetent or
people don't like me what sort of things
might you build like what am I talking
about when I talk talking about build
building on those beliefs
well they determine the choices you
might make you know if you think you're
not good enough then maybe there's
certain opportunities that will come up
that you could go for but which you
decide not to you know I won't go for
that promotion because I'm not good
enough or this person's invited me to
their
dinner party but I know they don't like
me really and no nor does everybody else
so I'm gonna turn it down Etc
now in case that's still too abstract
think of Imagine
somebody else being told imagine imagine
knowing somebody who you love who you're
close to and imagine they're in a
relationship with a partner who says
these sorts of things to you you know
they're married to somebody who says to
them things like you're not good enough
or you're incompetent or nobody likes
you I mean that would seem
we say these sorts of things to
ourselves and thinks that there's
nothing wrong with it right but then
when we imagine it said to somebody that
we love then we might see the problem
and perhaps you can get an intuitive
grasp there of the sort of problems that
those those sorts of things might cause
in in that person's life
so here's that philosophy to the rescue
uh there's some techniques
from philosophy that you can use here
one is to find the beliefs in the first
place to be open and curious about what
those beliefs might be that kind of
guide the way we move through the world
and to be open to rejecting them if they
turn out not to be
Justified
now this is what Descartes did in the
17th century
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas